antes de contestar el teléfono, se puede adivinar
o predecir qué se va a tratar en la llamada.
Esto se debe a una inyección de inteligencia al proceso,
que estaba considerando muerto en Occidente desde hace tiempo.
Y el último tipo de innovación, innovación invisible
de la India es lo que llamamos gestión de innovación.
No son productos o procesos nuevos
sino una nueva forma de organizar el trabajo
y la gestión de innovación más relevante de la India,
inventada por la industria de subcontratos al exterior hindú,
que llamamos modelo de entrega global.
El modelo de entrega global permite tomar
tareas centrales previamente asignadas geográficamente,
separarlas en partes que se envían alrededor del mundo
donde tengan la experiencia y la estructura de costos
para luego especificar los medios y reintegralos.
Sin esto, no podrían tener ninguna de las
innovaciones invisibles actuales.
Lo que intento decir, lo que hemos hallado
en nuestra investigación es que si los productos para usuarios finales
son la punta visible del iceberg de la innovación,
India está bien representada en la gran e invisible
porción sumergida del iceberg de la innovación.
Por supuesto, esto tiene algunas implicaciones,
tres de las cuales estudiamos en esta investigación.
La primera es la que llamamos la escalera de habilidad sumergida,
y ahora voy a regresar al inicio de mi charla
sobre la fuga de cerebros.
Por supuesto, en un inicio, como una compañía multinacional,
decidimos subcontratar la I+D a la India,
lo que íbamos a hacer era subcontratar el peldaño
más bajo de la escalera a la India, los trabajos menos sofisticados
justo como Tom Friedman lo predijera.
Entonces lo que sucede cuando subcontratas el peldaño más bajo
de la escalera de la innovación y la I+D a la India,
es que llega un momento en el futuro cercano donde
tienes que confrontar un problema:
¿de dónde viene la gente del siguiente
paso de la escalera dentro de la compañía?
Tienen entonces dos opciones:
ya sea que lleven a la gente de la India
al mundo desarrollado y ocupe puestos en el siguiente paso
de la escalera -inmigración-
o bien, hay tanta gente en el peldaño más bajo
de la escalera esperando el siguiente puesto en la India,
que ¿por qué no mover el siguiente peldaño a la India?
Lo que intentamos decir es que
una vez que subcontratas el peldaño más bajo de la escalera,
se vuelve un acto de auto perpetuación, por la simple
razón de que en la escalera de habilidad sumergida
no puedes ser un banquero inversionista
sin haber sido alguna vez un analista.
No puedes ser un profesor sin haber sido un estudiante.
No puedes ser un consultor sin haber sido un investigador asociado.
Entonces si subcontratas los trabajos menos sofisticados,
llega el momento de tomar el siguiente paso de la escalera.
La segunda cosa por mencionar es lo que llamamos
el bronceado de los equipos de alta gerencia TMT (en inglés).
Si el talento de I+D se va a ubicar fuera de la India
y China, y los mercados en crecimiento más grandes
van a estar en la India y China,
tienen que confrontar el problema de que
su alta dirección del futuro
provendrá de la India y China,
porque es allí donde está el liderazgo de producto,
donde está el liderazgo de mercado importante.
¿Cierto? Y la última cosa que resaltamos en esta diapositiva,
es que esta historia tiene una advertencia.
India tiene la población más joven en crecimiento del mundo.
Esta cuota demográfica es increíble y a la vez paradójica,
también tiene el espejismo de grupos de labor poderosos,
instituciones hindúes y sistema educativo,
salvo algunas excepciones, incapaces de producir
estudiantes en cantidades y calidades
que mantengan funcionando esta máquina de innovación.
Así las compañías están encontrando innovaciones para superar esto,
pero al final esto no absuelve al gobierno de la
responsabilidad de crear la estructura educacional.
Por último quiero concluir
mostrándoles el perfil de una compañía, IBM.
Como muchos de Uds. saben, IBM ha sido siempre considerada
una de las compañías más innovadoras
en los últimos cien años.
De hecho si miran la historia del número de patentes solicitadas
creo que están entre las dos o tres a la cabeza
en el mundo de todas las patentes solicitas en Estados Unidos por una compañía privada.
Aquí está el perfil de empleados de
IBM en la última década.
En 2003, tenían 300 000 empleados,
de los cuales, 135 000 eran de los
Estados Unidos y 9000 de la India.
En 2009, tenían 400 000 empleados, de los cuales
de Estados Unidos se redujeron a 105 000,
mientras que de la India subieron a 100 000.
Para el 2010, decidieron ya no publicar más
los datos, así que tuve que hacer algunas estimaciones
con base a varias fuentes.
Esta es mi mejor estimación ¿sí? No estoy diciendo
que sea una cifra exacta, es mi mejor estimación;
da una idea de la tendencia.
IBM tiene ahora 433 000 empleados, de los que
98 000 son de Estados Unidos
y 150 000 son de la India.
Díganme entonces, ¿es IBM una compañía estadounidense
o una compañía hindú? (Risas)
Damas y caballeros, muchas gracias (Aplausos)